we have a David Pakman show sub Reddit, which
has nearly 11,000 subscribers from our audience.
Now you can find it at David pakman.com/reddit
people ask me, David, why don't you give us
the actual reddit address because it's very
long. It's reddit.com/r/the David Pakman show.
It's much easier to just say David pakman.com/reddit
I got a couple of emails last week. People
saying, David, you're trying to get phony
traffic to your website by using a redirect.
No, I'm not. It's just easier to say David
pakman.com/reddit it will redirect you to
our sub reddit. A couple of notable posts
and discussions from the last couple of days
that I want to point out to you once again,
another post saying, I really want Dave to
debate Candace. Um, I don't know if that debate
is ever going to happen. A lot of you may
remember that at one point it seemed as though
Kyle Kalinsky and I were going to do a two
on two debate with a conservative people I'm
lacking in, in uh, uh, the right words here,
conservative individuals, Candice Owens and
Charlie Kirk at Politiken 2018 back in October
in Los Angeles. It turns out that I guess
they were never really doing it or at least
Kandace was not. And then it looked as though
I was told a third party that was organizing
a debate that Candice Owens had agreed in
principle to debate.
Man. We were just finalizing topics and the
dates. Tentatively one of those dates was
March 18th. As you might know, looking at
a calendar March 18th has long had come and
gone. And it doesn't seem at this point that
there's any reasonable opportunity for me
to debate. Candice owns. It doesn't seem that
she wants to do it. To be clear, it's not
me that is holding it up. It is Candace. And
that invitation remains open also from the
David Pakman show, sub Reddit, a post pointing
out that there is a Dave Ruben event in Rocklin,
California on June 22nd and a couple of people
in the comments said that they are planning
to go and what should they ask related to
the David Pakman show? So let, I'll, I'll
just tell you right now because you might
remember Dave Rubin recently said during a
public event when asked about interviewing
me that he um, is not against it in principle,
but that I've lied about him many times.
He said, Pac man has lied about me a bunch
of times and I've asked for and others have
been asking for what those lies were. So if
you go to a Dave Rubin event event and you
get the opportunity to ask a question, a question
that will almost definitely get the video
clip on the show is asking Dave Ruben, what
specific lies did David Pakman tell about
you? That would be a really great question
to ask. They Ruben. Another great question
for Dave Rubin. Did you watch and if so, what
did you think of David Pacman's Joe Rogan
appearance? Uh, another question would be,
David Pakman has said he would like to talk
to you publicly about the rift between the
two of you. Are you willing to do that? What
preconditions would you need? Like if, if
Dave, if David Pakman was willing to not mention
the phrase a marketplace of ideas, for example,
would you, would that be a reasonable precondition
for you to agree to a conversation with David
Pakman?
Do you think you and David Pakman will ever
reconcile your relationship? Would be an interesting
question for Dave Rubin. And I think most
people in our audience who are aware of what's
going on can probably come up on their own
with other, uh, interesting and relevant questions
for Dave Rubin at his events video of which
would almost be guaranteed to make it onto
the program. Presuming the audio and video
quality is good, please no vertical recording
record horizontally or Zantel recording much
more likely to make it onto the program. These
and many other interesting conversations including
others about policy. It's not all about gossip
within the online media community happening
with almost 11,000 of our viewers and listeners
daily on the David Pakman show, sub reddit
David pakman.com/r e d d I t